the challenge is in the modern world
where the biological systems are dynamic
we have to think on increasingly
large-scale international scale more of
a problem in Europe actually than it is
here because we're split into ridiculous
number of countries but in so because
each country sees its own species as its
problem and and Spain doesn't want to
give Britain a population of Iberian
lynx the most endangered species of cat
arguably on the planet because it's
their Ling's the Brits don't want the
Spanish lynx because it didn't occur in
Britain before nasty foreign Lynx's
actually it did about 150 thousand years
ago its ancestors but they've forgotten
that so but so what Brits are going to
do is to reintroduce if they possibly
can there's a whole group of people
working on it now to reintroduce the
Eurasian Lynx which and spend a lot of
money on doing this when actually it's
about the most widespread and least
endangered cat species on the planet now
for me given that we're living with
dynamic systems why not put your effort
and money into the species that's
genuinely endangered rather than
imagining putting links back in the Home
Counties is going to make the world
somehow good again